اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه
المستمره من العربيه ساعه اخباريه جديده
نبداها بابرز العناوين
مواجهاته متفرقه في الخرطوم تخرق الهدنه
والجيش يحبط هجوما للدعم السريع شمالك
كردفا
مصر تبلغ موظفين اللاجئين بدخول اكثر من
56 الف سوداني الى اراضيها منذ بدء
الاشتباكات
وفي اخبارنا ايضا
يصف الهجوم على الكرملين بالعمل الاداء
ويتوعد بان روسيا سترد بخطوات ملموسه
لندن تستكمل استعداداتها لحفل تتويج الملك
تشارلز الثالث بانتظار بدءته زعماء العالم
[موسيقى]
تشهد العاصمه السودانيه مواجهات متقطعه
منذ ساعه الصباح وذلك بعد اعلان الطرفين
الموافقه على هدنه جديده لاثنتين وسبعين
سنه
وفادت الانباب بان سلاح الجو السودانيه
نفذت طلعات جويه في محيط الاذاعه
والتلفزيون وجنوب مدينه ام درمان
اعلنت شركه الاتصالات ام تي ان توقف
خدمتها في الخرطوم عن العمل وذلك بسبب
توقف مقاسم الشركه في الخرطوم عن العمل ما
ادى لانقطاع جميع الخدمات عن المشتركين
جراء انقطاع الامداد الكهربائي وقالت شركه
انها تعمل على استعاده خدماتها وايجاد
حلول في اقرب وقت
قبل ذلك اكدت قوات الدعم السريع في بيان
لها قبولها تمديد الهدنه 72 ساعه بواسطه
سعوديه امريكيه والالتزام بوقف اطلاق
النار كما اعلن الدعم السريع ترحيبه
بالمبادرات المحليه والاقليميه والدوليه
لوقف اطلاق النار بهدف فتح ممرات انسانيه
وتسهيل حركه المواطنين
ومع استمرار خرق الهدنه في السودان اعلن
الجيش السوداني له عن احباط هجوم لقوات
الدعم السريع على مدينه الاوبيض بشمال
كردفان حيث توجد ثاني اكبر حاميه عسكريه
في البلاد وفرض سيطره كامله على المدينه
واوضح البيان ان قوه من الجيش الشبكه مع
الدعم السريع وكبدته خسائر كبيره في
الارواح مع تدمير ثلاث مركبات واضف الجيش
السوداني بان الدعم السريع شن هجوما على
معسكر تدريب في جبل كردفان اسفره عن مقتل
15 عسكريا بينهم اثنان من الضباط كما لحقت
مجموعات من الهجان التابعه للجيش عناصر
الدعم السريع في عدد من شوارع وازقه
المدينه وفق البيان
وانضم الى نمو الخرطوم الصحفي عمار ابو
شيبه اهلا بك عمار قبل الحديث عما يدور في
الخرطوم هل هدات المواجهات في الابيض
وانتهت ونتائج هذه الاشتباكات بين قوات
الجيش والدعم السريع
نعم يعني بحسب المعلومات الكثيره جدا التي
وردت من ولايه شمال كردفان ومن مدينه
الاوبيض تحدثت هذه المعلومات ان الجيش من
خلال الفرقه الخامسه الهجانه استطاع هجوم
قوات الدعم السريعه على تلك المنطقه وبسط
عدد
عمار نحن ونحن نتحدث معك نشاهد هذه الصور
التي تاتينا مباشره من الخرطوم ويظهر فيها
دهان كثيف في قلب العاصمه هذا الدخان رافق
ربما التحليق المكثف للطيران اليوم واصوات
الانفجارات ربما كان هناك فتره هدوء نسبي
لكن عادت الامور
لتتجدد الاشتباكات ونشاهد في الصوره ربما
انفجار ودخان كثيف في العاصمه الخرطوم اذا
تطورات جديده
وتجدد الاشتباكات في اكثر من منطقه سنعود
الحديث عن هذا الموت
للحديث عن هذه النقطه تحديدا لكن عندما
تنتهي من المعلومات المتعلقه في الابيض
نعم يعني بحسب المعلومات التي دارت من او
خرجت من المدينه الابيض تحدثت بشكل واضح
ان الجيش استطاع ان يبسط السيطره على
المدينه وخرجت الاشتباكات بعد ان كانت في
عدد من الاحياء هذه الاشتباكات خلفت عدد
كثير يعني اكثر من تسعه قتله داخل المدينه
بحسب مصادر طبيه
الصوره ربما دعنا نستمع لما يحدث في
الخرطوم ونركز على التطورات الاحداث فيها
هل تشاهد انت ما يحدث من خلفك لو تطلعنا
على طبيعه ما يحدث اذا كنت تتابع هذه
الصوره
نعم هذا المكان هو ليس ببعيد من المنطقه
التي نتواجد فيها الان هو ربما بالقرب من
شارع افريقيا شارع المطار الذي يقود الى
هذه المنطقه الاستراتيجيه كانت قبل دقائق
من هذا المباشر طلع جويه للطيران الحربي
نفذ من خلالها
استهدافا لعدد من المواقع في هذه المنطقه
لم نتاكد بعد ما طبيعه هذا الاستهداف هل
هو لقوات متحركه ام متمركزه ام ماذا هي
هذه المعلومات من هذه المنطقه ولكن كان
هذا كان يعني هذا الانفجار قبل اكثر او
اقل من خمسه دقائق من الان الان راى اعمده
الدخان تتصاعد من هذا المكان
وهذه المنطقه منطقه ماهوله بالسكان نشاهد
عدد من الابراج وتجمعات السكنيه في شارع
افريقيا وفي منطقه العمارات وربما ايضا
عدد من المناطق المجاوره لهذه المنطقه قد
خ فيها كثير من المواطنين في هذه المنطقه
ولكن هذا الانفجار
نلاحظ فيه الان ان ارتفاع مثل الدخان من
خلال غاره جويه نفذها الطيران الحربي على
هذا المكان بحسب طبيعه المنطقه دارت فيها
اشتباكات وهذا الطريق المهم شارع افريقيا
يقود الى المطار الخرطوم ومن ثم الى قياده
الجيش وهي مواقع استراتيجيه دارت فيها
اشتباكات منذ اليوم الاول وحتى من خلال
نشاهده ظهور جديد هذه سحابه دخان كثيفه
جدا وليست اعمده الدخان يعني هل يشير هذا
الامر الى ربما استخدام استهداف مخازن
اسلحه او ذخيره لانه الدخان الكثيف ربما
لا يشير الى
استهداف ربما دوريه او ما شابه
نعم كما قلت قبل قليل لم نتاكد بعد ما
طبيعه الاستهداف في هذه المنطقه ولكن هذا
جراء قصف للطيران كان قبل دقائق من الدخول
لهذا المباشر ونلاحظ بان هذه السحابه
الكثيفه الان تتشكل وهذه منطقه كما ذكرت
لك قبل قليل هي ماهوله بالسكان وبها عدد
من التجمعات السكانيه من خلال الابراج
سكانيه معروفه وترتكز فيها عدد من الاسواق
التجاريه والمحال التجاريه التي اغلقت
بفعل الاشتباكات في هذه المنطقه ربما
نحتاج لعدد من الدقائق حتى نتاكد اكثر ما
طبيعه هذا الاستهداف ولماذا هذه السحابه
تشكلت بهذا الشكل ربما هنالك ايضا
مستودعات لوقود او او مستودعات لعدد من
المحاله التجاريه او ربما اهداف كانت
مرتكزه في هذه المنطقه ولكن هذه المنطقه
بالنسبه التقريبيه هي في الشارع المطار
وربما بالقرب مول عفراء هذا المول الذي
ايضا تعرض للنهب والسلب في عدد من المرات
الكثيره جدا جراء هذه الاشتباكات الصوره
ما زالت توضح حجم الانفجار وحجم السحابه
الذي يتكون شيئا في المنطقه الغربيه من
هذا المكان منطقه سكنيه وبالتالي
توقعاتك بنتائج قصف جوي على منطقه سكنيه
ليس بها مواقع عسكريه كيف يمكن ان تكون
النتائج
نعم هي منطقه سكنيه ولكن دارت فيها
اشتباكات باعتبار ان الطريقه الذي يشق هذه
المنطقه الرئيسيه والسكنيه الطريقه الرئيس
هو شارع افريقيا يقود للمطار وهذه المنطقه
تتجمع فيها عدد من الاحياء السكنيه نعم
لكن حسب عدد من المعلومات كثير جدا من
اهالي هذه المنطقه غادروها باعتبار انها
تقع ما بين خطين خط شارع المطار مجرد فيه
اشتباكات عنيفه منذ اليوم الاول والسيطره
على المطار والخط الثاني هو شارع محمد
نجيب او المنطقه الغربيه التي تقود الى
سلاح المدرعات ومنطقه الغابه من خلال
الاتجاه الغربي وهذه المنطقه تدور فيها
اشتباكات ما بين الدعم السريع وقوات الجيش
التي تتمركز في الجانب الغربي من هذا
المكان هذه الغاره الجويه التي رفدها صلاح
قبل قليل استهدفت هذا المكان بشكل مباشره
وكنا نشاهد هذا الاستهداف قبل الدخول
المباشره انا الكاميرا توثق هذه السحابه
الضخمه ربما انهيار لابني سكنيه ربما عدد
من المستودعات موجوده في هذا المكان او
عدد من المحال التجاريه تعرضت لقصف نحن
سنعطيك سنعطيك بعض الوقت
التحقق من نتائج هذا الاستهداف والقصف
الجوي وما خرجت عنه ونعود لك بعد قليل
ربما
لتطلقنا على ما حدث لكن
سنبقي عينا على هذه الصوره
ونعطيك فرصه
لتستطلع حقيقه ما تم استهدافه ونتائج هذا
الاستهداف على كل حال ونحن نتابع الصوره
نشير الى عدد من الانباء المتعلقه بتطورات
الاوضاع في السودان حيث حذر عدد من
المتطوعين والنشاطين في جنوب دارفور اثناء
تنفيذ حمله صحيه بمستشفى نياله التعليميه
من عمليه تسليح الشباب داخل الاحياء
باقليم دارفور بحجه حمايتها معتبرين ان
الخطوه يمكنها ان تؤدي الى انزلاق البلاد
الى شبح الحرب الاهليه في ظل انعدام
الامني في دارفور
اذا جراء المعارك بين الجيش والدعم السريع
جنوب دارفور احترقت عده اسواق كانت في
مرمى النيران سوق التوابل او التوابل في
جنوب دارفور من اكبر الاسواق في غرب
افريقيا واقدمها تحول الى رماد بسبب هذه
الاشتباكات نتابع يعتبر سوق التوابل
بمدينه نيالا غربيه السودان احد اكبر
الاسواق في غرب افريقيا
واعرقها هنا في اقليم دارفور القذائف التي
سقطت عليه جراء الاشتباكات بين الجيش
والدعم السريع في احداثي الخامس عشر من
ابريل حولت السوق الى رماد الخسائر كبيره
بحسب حديثه ليله الحصر احنا الان في سوق
الشطه يعني الخسائر بتاعتنا تفوق
التريليون حجم البضائع اضافه لذلك المباني
والممتلكات الخاصه
والمستندات وكل التفاصيل انتهت الان يعني
لا نقول الا ما يرضي الله انا لله وانا
اليه راجعون على الرغم من الدمار ويحاول
عيسى موسى اصلاح المكان وتلبيه احتياجات
زبائن رغم من المعاناه والتعب ولابد لنا
من انه نقدح ونعمل لاعاده تاهيل السوق
ولكي نكسب ونعيش ونؤهل نفسنا ونرمم ما
تدمر من جراء الحرب في مجتمع يكابد للخروج
من ازمات عديده تاتي هذه الحرب هنا في
اقليم دارفور لتضيف عبئا اخر على حياته
وتنضم الينا من الخرطوم رئيس التحرير
صحيفه تغيير رشا عوض اهلا بك استاذه رشا
اذا نتحدث معك ونحن نتابع هذه الصور
المباشره والخاصه بقناه العربيه والتي
تظهر ربما سحابه دخان تشكلت بفعل قصف جوي
استهدف منطقه في العاصمه الخرطوم اذا
اليوم هو اليوم الحادي والعشرين من هذه
الاشتباكات كل الهدن التي تمت الموافقه
عليها تخللتها خروقات من بينها قصف جوي
تعليقك على ما يحدث وحجم الالتزام ونتائجه
وتداعيات هذا على السكان
بدءا التحيه لك والتحيه لمشاهدي قناه
العربيه ما يحدث يمكن قراءته في سياق امن
الجيش السوداني لم يوقف الغارات الجويه
ولن يوقف الاشتباكات العنيفه جدا بالاسلحه
الثقيله ما دامت المناطق الاستراتيجيه
التي استولى عليها الدعم السريع ما زالت
في قبضته وعلى راسها القياده العامه للجيش
ومطار الخرطوم والقصر الجمهوري والاذاعه
والتلفزيون
فهناك تصميم على خوض المعارك مهما ارتفعت
السلفه الانسانيه ومهما كان تاثير ذلك على
السكان وعلى الاقتصاد وعلى مستقبل البلاد
ولذلك منذ البدايه لم نتفاعل بالاعلام عن
اي هبله لان هناك اصرار على تحقيق مكاسب
او اختصارات في الميدان تؤدي في خاتمه
المطاف الى تحسين الوضع لو كانت هناك
مفاوضات
مؤكد هو الحصمه العسكري ثبت بالتجربه
العمليه انه مستحيل بدليل اننا الان
اكملنا الاسبوع الثالث تحت هذه الحرب ولا
حسم عسكري هناك اشتباكات هناك مواجهه
تكسير عظام
اتساع في رقعه الحرب نفسها الحاذبون على
مستقبل السودان
والذين يتالمون فعلا لمعاناه السكان لدينا
الان اكثر من نصف مليون نادئ تركوا
منازلهم ولدينا ازمه انسانيه متفاقمه
الحاذبون على مصلحه السودان ينادون بالحل
السياسي التفاوضي ووقف هذه الحرب فورا
ولكن للاسف اعداء السلام واعداء الشعب
يريدون استمرار الحرب ويريدون تحويلها
عقيده هؤلاء اما ان يحكموا البلاد واما ان
يحرقوها بالكامل ويشرد سكانها الان ماضون
في هذا السيناريو الماساوي لا ادري كيف
يمكن ذبح هذه الشرور وقبح هذه القوه
الشريره التي تريد تدمير السودان ولكن
للاسف نحن الان اصبحنا ريهامين لمنطقه
الحرب الداخلي
ودلامياتها الخاصه في الاستمرار وفي
التوسع فقط نذكر مشاهدينا باننا نتابع هذه
الصور الخاصه بقناه العربيه من قلب
العاصمه الخرطوم ويظهر بها سحابه دخان
كبيره نتجت عن قصف جوي اكد لنا الصحفي
المتعاون مع قناه العربيه انه حدث قبل نحو
15 دقيقه
واستهدف احد المواقع بالقرب من المطار
ونتجت عنها هذه السحابه الكبيره من الدخان
الى الان لا نعلم ما الذي تم استهدافه لكن
الصوره ربما تتحدث عن نفسها ولا اعلم
استاذه رشاد الانباء ايضا تشير الى انقطاع
تام للاتصالات في العاصمه الخرطوم وخدمات
الانترنت بفعل انقطاع الكهرباء الذي طال
ايضا خمس ولايات وبالتالي في كل يوم تزداد
الامور سوءا فيما يتعلق بال وضع الانساني
هل يمكن ان نستمر هذا الوضع الى ما لا
نهايه ومن يملك القدره على وقف هذا النزاع
بالفعل الوضع اخذ في التدهور الانترنت حتى
في الاماكن التي يوجد فيها بعيد عن
الخرطوم هو ضعيف جدا الازمه الانسانيه
متفاقمه والشعب السوداني من جانبه ممثلا
في قواها السياسيه وفي منظماته وفي كل
تقويماته الحيه هنا صوت قوي يقول اوقفوا
هذه الحرب نعم للسلام نعم للحل التفاوضي
هناك مبادرات دوليه واقليميه
هناك عقوبات مثلا قرار الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن بمعاقبه من يعقلون السلام
والاستقرار في السودان ولكن كل هذه
المبادرات
المتقاتلين
ولان هناك من يدفع في استمرار الحرب ويدفع
نحو التصعيد
نحن الان امام خيارين اولا لابد ان يكون
هناك
منهج لاداره الازمه الانسانيه في السودان
لاحتواء اثار الحرب لانها يبدو انها ستطول
وهناك مسار سياسي هذا المسار السياسي
يتوقف على مدى الضغوط التي تمارسها الدول
التي لها تاثير على طرفي القتال حتى
يذعلوا للحل التفاوضي والاشكاليه ان الذي
يظهر انها هي حرب بين الجيش وبين الدعم
السريع ولكن هناك الفصيل الاسلامي
والانقلاب المختبئ خلف الجيش والذي يلعب
دوره في تخريب اي تحرك نحو حل قياسي او حل
تلمي ويعمل على تاثير
الجيش بالطريقه غير مباشره مسؤوليه
استمرار هذه المواجهه يعني نحن تابعنا
تصريحات الدعم السريع وقوه الجيش ربما
الجيش اكد بان كل الهدن التي وافق عليها
هي لاسباب انسانيه هل يمكن قراءه موقف
الجيش بانه سيمضي قدما في هذه المواجهه
حتى القضاء على قوات الدعم السريع هل هذا
الامر يعني صحيح كما فهمته
هذا هو السيناريو المفروض على الجيش من
قبل قيادات عسكريه في جيش تابعه للنظام
الاسلامي هناك في الجيش راي اخر هناك في
الجيش من يرى ان هذه الحرب مفروضه على
الجيش وان هذه الحرب اندلعت في توقيت
بحسابات
التكتير
وبالحرب انها اعلنت في توسيع في في توقيت
غير مناسب وان الجيش بهذه الحرب ولكن كما
نعلم التمكين الاسلامي وعلى مدى 30 امم
طال كل المؤسسات بما فيها الجيش وهذا
التمكين من اثاره هو هذه الحرب التي نراها
والان الخطاب السائد في اوساط الاسلاميين
هو ضروره التخلص من البرهان نفسه لانهم
راوا ان القران يميل الى الحل السياسي او
الى المفاوضات الان اذا كان هناك رغبه في
ايقاف هذه الحرب فلنعلم من هو طرف الحقيقي
الذي يؤيدها والذي يدعو الى تصعيدها الى
ما لا نهايه شكرا جزيلا لك رشا عوض رئيس
التحرير صحيفه التغيير كنت معنا عبر
الهاتف من الخرطوم ونذكر مشاهدينا بان هذه
الصور تاتينا مباشره وصور خاصه بقناه
العربيه وتظهر اث ضربه جويه نفذتها قوات
الجيش قبل نحو نصف ساعه في قلب العاصمه
الخرطوم
مشاهدينا اذا نتابع معكم هذه الصور التي
تاتينا مباشره والخاصه بقناه العربيه
لسحابه دخان ضخمه تشكلت ويبدو ان هناك
حريقا كبيرا بفعل قصف جوي على احد الاهداف
في العاصمه الخرطوم تشكلت بفعله هذه
السحابه الكبيره التي غطت سماء العاصمه
الخرطوم كان سمع صوت تحليق للطائرات اليوم
في خلق جديد للهدنه التي وافقت طرفان
عليها والان من ما نتابع بهذه الصور
الخاصه بالعربيه يبدو ان هناك حريقا كبيرا
تشكل بفعل هذا القصف الجوي الذي اكدت
مصادر العربيه انه جاء بعد تحليق للطائرات
في سماء العاصمه الخرطوم
طبعا هذه الصور مشاهدينا التي نتابعها بين
الفين والاخرى نستمع الى اصوات مواجهات
بالاسلحه الخفيفه والثقيله والرشاشات
رغم ان مصادر العربيه اكدت ان هذه المنطقه
منطقه سكنيه لكن بفعل المواجهات التي
استمرت على مدى ثلاثه اسابيع غادر معظم
سكان المنطقه منازلهم الى مناطق اكثر امنا
ونزح الكثير من سكان العاصمه الخرطوم الى
ولايات اخرى
اقل خطرا ولا توجد بها اشتباكات مثل ما
يحدث حول المناطق الاستراتيجيه ومن بينها
منطقه المطار القريبه من موقع الاستهداف
الذي نشاهد صوره الان
طبعا هذه الاشتباكات المستمره منذ ثلاثه
اسابيع والهدن التي لم يتم الالتزام بها
شكلت ربما كارثه انسانيه ووضعا صعبا في
الكثير من المناطق خصوصا
العاصمه السودانيه اذا هذه صور اقرب لموقع
الاستهداف
اذا مشاهدينا كما تحدثنا يعني الوضع في
السودان حسب كثير من المراقبين
والمحللين يتجه الى ربما كارثه حقيقيه في
ظل انقطاع الماء والكهرباء والاتصالات عن
الكثير من الولايات وايضا شح في المواد
الاساسيه وحتى ارتفاع
تكاليف
المواصلات والانتقال لمن يرغب بمغادره
المناطق المحتدمه ايضا هناك
مناطق اخرى تشهد اشتباكات من بينها الابيض
التي شهدت اليوم معارك بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع جنوب دارفور واحترقت بسببها
عده اسواق وايضا
يعود لنا عمار
ابو شيبه الصحفي ليعلق معنا على هذه الصور
لا ادري اذا كنت جمعت معلومات حول طبيعه
هذا الاستهداف ونتائجه
قبل قليل بان هذا الاستهداف شكل استهدافا
لعدد من المستودعات وعدد ربما الولايات
التي كانت تتمركز فيها قوات ولكن هذه
المعلومات حتى الان هي معلومات اوليه
نحتاج ربما لمصادر اكثر للتاكد من ذلك
وهنالك اشارات من هذه المنطقه باعتبار ان
الجيش كان قد نشر عدد من قواته في منطقه
شارع الغابه وهذا الشارع الغربي الذي يقود
الى الشارع المطار من الجانب الاخر وهنالك
ايضا عدد من الاحياء المجاوره والبنايات
الكبيره جدا التي من خلالها توجد عدد من
التجمعات السكانيه الكبيره
وهذا الحديث ايضا قبل قليل يعني
شاهدنا طلعات للطيران الحربي يشن قارات
جويه على هذه المنطقه
المناطق المجاوره لها ايضا قبل قليل قبل
دقائق من الان عاده طيران مره اخرى
وليست تحدي قلعات الجويه في وسط العاصمه
وفي هذه المنطقه التي هي في شارع افريقيا
شارع المطار وهنا تدور معارك عنيفه منذ
عده ايام السيطره على المطار والسيطره
وهذه المناطق المحيطه بالمطار وهو يعتبر
ايضا بانه بعد يجي في محيط المطار يمكن من
خلاله السيطره على المطار اذا ما
تمضي لاي هجوم في هذه المنطقه يعني نفهم
منك بانه حتى الان وبعد هذا الاستهداف ما
زال هناك تحليق للطائرات في سماء الخرطوم
نعم الطائرات استهدفت اكثر من هدف في هذا
المكان دقائق من الان
حتى بعض الاستهداف الاول ما زالت الطائرات
السادسه هذا المكان بشكل واضح نستمع الى
ربما المبدقه الارضيه رد
بكثاف في هذه المنطقه
فهي من المناطق المجاوره في وسط العاصمه
الخرطومه الطائره ايضا ليس ببعيدا عن هذا
المكان نفذت قرار جويه قبل دقائق في
المنطقه الغربيه وسط العاصمه الخرطوم
شاهدنا من خلالها ايضا تصاعد للتخان
وكثافه من السحب من الغبار في هذه المنطقه
ما زالت هذه الطائرات تحلق وترد عليها
المضادات الارضيه بكثافه من كافه
الاتجاهات ما يعني ان هنالك اهدافا ربما
تتحرك على الارض او تتمركز في هذه المناطق
وجعل هذا المكان منطقه للاستهداف المنصه
الحربي ذكرت بانه هذه النقطه تحديدا تم
استهدافها بالطائرات اكثر من مره يعني
الطائرات قصفتها ثم عادت وقصفتها مره اخرى
هل يشير هذا الامر الى انه هناك
صيد ثمين اذا ما جاز التعبير في هذه
المنطقه تكثف الطائرات ضربه والدلالات هذه
الادخنه هل هناك طريق في المنطقه هل لديكم
معلومات ما اذا كان هناك حريق الان مشتعل
في هذه المنطقه
نعم
ولكن هذا المتوقع عباره عن هذه البنيه هذه
المنطقه بها عدد كبير من التجمعات
السكانيه او البنايات السكانيه وكذلك
المخالف التجاريه هو ايضا ربما عدد من
المستودعات في هذه المنطقه لكن هناك اشاره
ايضا في هذه المنطقه كانت تتحرك عدد من
القوات قوات الدعم السريع وتتحرك ايضا
قوات الجيش في حرب وربما هناك قيادات لهذه
المنطقه كما جعل
الطيران هذه المنطقه بهذا الشكل
الارضيه المتمركزه في هذه المنطقه بكثافه
هذه المنطقه ربما هي لم تشهد
الطيران بهذا الشكل هذا هذه المره الاولى
التي نشاهد من خلالها ما هذا القصف المكثف
لهذه المنطقه بالتحديد وما فيها ربما من
اهداف عسكريه بحسب ربما او بحسب معلومات
ورد
من خلال هذه المنطقه
المجاوره لهذه المنطقه هذه المناطق اخرى
هذه القرارات الجويه وادور على هذه
الدفاعات الجويه التابعه لقوه الدعم
السريع هل هي فعاله في التصدي لهذه
الطائرات ام ان هذه الطائرات تقصف من
ارتفاعات عاليه خصوصا بانها يعني تعمل
بحريه على ما يبدو في مناطق الاشتباكات
هناك
المضادات الارضيه الكلاسيكيه
ولكن لم نشاهد او نلحظ بان هذه المضادات
الارضيه
تتطابقه
الطيران الحربي باستثناء
النقل
التركيه التي كانت في منطقه وال سيدنا
واتهم الجيش قوات الدعم السريع بانها ان
نفذت تلك الطلاقات على الطائره الدعم
السريع ذلك لكن
طيران حربي للقوات المسلحه هناك كثير
من الجسيمات التي تتحدث عن اسقاط طائرات
لكن لم يتم التاكد منها بشكل فعلي وصحيح
اعود مره اخرى لهذه المنطقه الان وهي ليست
ببعيده عن عدد من المؤشرات
في منطقه الرياض منطقه
هرعت الى هذه المنطقه ام هناك غياب ربما
لفرق الانقاذ في مثل هذه الحالات
جيدا ربما يطلب الوصول لهذه المنطقه للطرق
للفرا بشكل واضح غير فعاله في هذه الازمه
منذ الايام الاولى كثير من المناسبات
وكثير
جدا ربما الامور التي ترتب هذا المسار
باعتبار
سيارات الاسعاف وعدد كبير جدا من الطاقم
الطبيه لا يستطيع الوصول الى المستشفيات
فكيف له ان يصل الى مرافق وربما هذه
المنطقه
عدد او بالقرب من
هذا منطقه الرياض خصوصا وهذا المعسكر كان
قد كتبت الايام الاولى
في اليوم الاول من بدايه هذه الحرب وربما
عاده من جديد
نلاحظ هذه الاشاره خاصه لان المضادات
الارضيه هي من كافه الاتجاهات في منطقه
شرق الخرطوم الغربيه
ضمن هذه المنطقه التي فيها هذا الاشتباك
الجوي وتعود عليه المضادات يعني ان عمليه
القذف مستمره وعمليه الرد من المتضربه
الارضيه المستعمله ربما هنا لتدور عدد
المعارك على الارض يساهم فيها سلاح
الطيران بعمليه شبكه هوائيه من خلالها
يستطيع تسيير عدد من المهمات والمشاعر
الارض ربما ايضا سمع في لحظه ولحظه اخرى
المضاده العظيم الذي كنا نحتوي عليها قبل
قليل ايضا قبل لحظات
بالقرب من هذه المنطقه ربما بدا استخدام
مدفعيه في هذه المنطقه وربما الكثير
ومتوقعه في هذا المكان هل الامر ينسحب على
منطقه مدينه بحري وايضا ام درمان كيف يبدو
المشهد هناك خصوصا ان التقارير اشارت الى
انه هناك تحليق مكثف ايضا للطيران في
منطقه ام درمان
نعم كان هذا منذ صباح الباكر وحتى
الماضيه خاصه مدينه بحري حيث نفذ فيها
الطيران الحربي عدد من
المواقعت من خلال الصناعات الجويه خاصه
منطقه الحله وموقع البابورات المعروفه
الشهير والذي
ربما باعتبار انه يحاول النيل ويحاد القصر
الجمهوري والقياده العامه من الاتجاه
الشمالي لمدينه بحرين على مستوى مدينه
كانت هنالك طلعات لسلاح الجوف نفذ فيها
ايضا عدد من المواقع واستهدف هذه المواقع
ولكن
البحر وما نشاهده الان في وسط العرب
الخرطوم وهذه الطائرات ما جاءت تطلق وما
زال تنفذ عدد من الاهداف في وسط العاصمه
وترد عليها المضادات هذا الان هذا الوضع
الالي يشير الى ان عمليات الحث من العسكري
اصبحت واضحه الجيش يستخدم الطيران السلاحي
وقوات الدعم
على عدد كبير من الشوارع الرئيسيه
والفرعيه وتدل الكلام الشبكات
نستمع الى اخر المعلومات لديه
نتائج هذه المواجهات على الارض كيف يبدو
الوضع لديك محمد الان
الى دوري هذه الانفجارات كما ذكرت قبل
قليل يبدو بانها منطقه
المظلات اللي هي بالقرب من جسر الشمبان
هذه المنطقه يبدو من الواضح من خلال اعمده
الدخان التي بشاهدها في هذه اللحظات يبدو
انها تعرضت لقتل في هذه اللحظه اضافه الى
ان هناك بعض الاشتباكات تدور في منطقه
كافوري كما علمنا قبل قليل من بعض
المصادر اذن في الساعات الاخيره يبدو
باننا قد بدانا في الدخول الى موعد او
ساعه المعركه الجديده المعلنه والتي
لطالما تحدث عنها الجيش
في الساعات الماضيه باننا في الفتره او
الساع
ات ربما نشهد اشتباكات عنيفه
وعليها كما
ان
ضربات حاسمه وقاضيه هل يمكن اعتبار بما
يحدث الان بانه ربما اكبر خرق للهدن التي
تم التوافق عليها بين قوات الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع حتى الان
نعم ابراهيم دوما هذه الهدى لا يعني الناس
يشاهدونها
الشاشات والاعلام ولكن على ارض الواقع
مهما كانت هذه الهدى مبلغت خمس مدن
السادسه او السابعه لا يشعر بها الناس ولا
يشعر بها المواطن على ارض الواقع بينما
كلما اعلنت عنهن جديده تزداد الاشتباكات
وتزداد وتيره هذه المعارك فيما يتعلق
بسياسه الجيش يبدو ان الجيش يلجا
الى سلاح الجو والقسف الجوي اكثر من
المواجهات المباشره بين قوته وقوات الدعم
السريع باستثناء المواجهه الكبرى التي تم
الاعلان عنها عن جسر الحلفايه هل تم رسم
مواجهات من هذا النوع ام ان الجيش بدا
يلجا الى القصف عن بعد لتجمعات
ودوريات الدعم السريع في الخرطوم وباقي
المناطق
نعم ابراهيم دوما الجيش بدا القذف يتحاشى
المناطق السكنيه
وهذه وافيه بدليل
دخولتها على العديد من المشافي داخل ولايه
الخرطوم هذه المستشفيات المعروفه التي
كانت تقدم بعضها الخدمه للمواطنين دخول
الدعم السريع داخل هذه المشافي دلاله
وافيه بان
الجيش لا يستخدم هذا الغز
ف الا المناطق الم
فتوحه لكن هذه واحده من الاشكاليات التي
ربما استفدت المواطن ابراهيم
واثارت غضب الجيش في
التعقل
ودعوات الدعم السريع بهذه المستشفيات
واخرها مستشفى ام درمان التي قام بادخال
عربات لانه في ظل كل ما يحدث اليونيسيف
يؤكد نهب اكثر من مليون لقاح لشلل الاطفال
في السودان اذا خبر غريب نهب اكثر من
مليون لقاح لشلل الاطفال في السودان حسب
تاكيدات
اليونيسف على كل حال شكرا جزيلا لك محمد
اسحاق عثمان الصحفي كنت معنا من الخرطوم
بحري والشكر موصول ايضا للصحفي عمار ابو
شيبه كان معنا ايضا من الخرطوم عبر الهاتف
شكرا جزيلا لكم
في اخبار السودان ايضا ساهم الجيش وعلى مر
سنوات طويله في الحفاظ على الامن
والاستقرار الداخلي حتى الحدود ضمن
استراتيجيه عسكريه محكمه تمكن من خلالها
من مواجهه كافه التحديات والتهديدات
الحدوديه محتمله تفاصيل اكثر نتابعها مع
فارس صلواتي دوروا حيوي مهم لعبه الجيش
السوداني منذ استقلال البلاد في عام
1956 حيث كان الحفاظ على الاستقرار وتهدئه
الاضطرابات الداخليه ومواجهه التحديات
الحدوديه اولويه قصوى مناطق عسكريه ووحدات
قتاليه بريه ونقاط تفتيش عسكريه تابعه
للجيش السوداني موجوده على طول الحدود
التي تربطه بدول الجوار شمالا هنا حيث
الجار مصر توجد مناطق عسكريه تابعه للجيش
السوداني تحديدا جنوب مثلث حلايب في ولايه
البحر الاحمر كما توجد
الفرقه التاسع عشر بمدينه مروي والتي تطل
على طريق شريان الشمال الرابط بين مصر
والسودان على الضفه المقابله مثلث اخر على
الحدود الليبيه السودانيه هناك ايضا قاعده
مركزيه كبيره للجيش السوداني اما غربا
التشاد وبحدود بريه تزيد عن 2000 كيلو متر
مع السودان تنتشر فيها قوات مشتركه بهدف
تامين تلك الحدود فقط
وفي افريقيا الوسطى التي تمزقها الحرب
يوجد الجيش السوداني ضمن نقاط تفتيش
عسكريه عند الدخول والخروج اما على الحدود
السودانيه
يمكن والتي يمكن ان تتحول لقاعده لتدفق
السلاح ينتشر الجيش السوداني ضمن نقاط
تفتيش كبرى في كسلا والحدود المتاخمه مع
اريتريا ضمن حاميه عسكريه نقطه صراع
وعلى تلك الحدود المشتعله حينا وحين مع
اثيوبيا ينتشر الجيش السوداني في منطقه
الفشقه التي تقع في ولايه الجضارف وايضا
في منطقه الجلابات وولايه النيل الازرق
وفي جنوب البلاد هناك العديد من المناطق
العسكريه ينتشر فيها الجيش السوداني شمال
ابيي شمال ابيي كما نتابع وكذلك في
كوردوفان وولايه النيل الابيض حدود بريه
واسعه يتشاركها السودان مع دول عديده فرضت
على الجيش اتباع استراتيجيه تحكمها ضوابط
عسكريه لحمايه وتعزيز وجوده على طول
الشريط الحدودي
[موسيقى]
الان الى تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا
على وقع تصاعد المعارك في باخمه شرق
اوكرانيا اطلق مؤسس مجموعه فاغنار ايفغيني
بريكين تصريحات ناريه اتهم فيها وزير
الدفاع الروسيه سرقه ورئيس الاركان العامه
فاليري جراثيموف بانهم وراء النقص الكبير
في امدادات السلاح للمجموعه والذي يصل الى
سبعين في المئه حيث وصف بريجوجين ونشرت
الدائره الصحفيه للمجموعه مقطع فيديو يظهر
فيه مستاء من الوضع بشكل كبير ويتحدث
وخلفه مجموعه من جثث مقاتله
رئيس مجموعه فاجنر حذر من ان قواته ستغادر
مدينه باخمت في العاشر مما الجري بسبب عدم
تامين وزاره الدفاع الروسيه الذخيره لقوته
وقال ان استمرار القتال في باك موت من دون
ذخيره امر لا جدوى منه بالاضافه الى تكبد
خسائر بين مقاتلي فاجنر خلال المواجهات في
باخموت
بحلول التاسع من مايو قلنا على وشك
الاستيلاء على بخموت لكن بعد ان راوا هذا
التقدم اوقف البيروقراطيون شبه العسكريين
توريد الذخيره لمنعنا من القيام بذلك
يعتقدون انهم سوف يدخلون التاريخ ابلغت
وزير الدفاع ورئيسها هيئه الاركان والقائد
الاعلى رسميا بان رفاقي لن يتكبدوا خسائر
غير مبرره بدون ذخيره لذا في العشر من
مايو سننسحب من باغموت
هكذا وزير الخارجيه الروسي ان الهجوم على
كان عاملا عدائيا وروسيا سترد بخطوات
ملموسه واعتبر لابروف ان كييف لن تحاول
مهاجمه الكرملين من دون اخطار سادتها في
الغرب حسب وصفه وكشف وزير الخرج الروسي
ايضا ان موسكو مستعده للتحدث مع الغرب
وهذا سيحدث عاجلا ام اجلا
من جانبه حضر نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
من ان العلاقات الروسيه الامريكيه تقترب
من حافه المواجهه المسلحه مشيرا الى ان
موسكو تحاول الحفاظ على العلاقات مع
واشنطن لمنع سقوطها في هويه النزاع المسلح
واضاف بان روسيا مستعده لاستخدام كل
الوسائل الممكنه لضمان عدم السماح لاي جهه
بالتعد على امن روسيا وسلامه رئيسها
وقيادتها السياسيه
اكدت مصادر لوكاله سبوتنيك روسيه بان
الطيران الروسي شنه ضربه على نقطه تمركز
مدربين اجانب للقوات الاوكرانيه في منطقه
تشيرنيف الاوكرانيه حيث تجمع افراد واسلحه
واليات عسكريه اوكرانيا واضاف المصدر
للوكاله بان الوكاله بان القوات المسلحه
الروسيه دمرت ايضا مجموعتين استطلاعيتين
تابعتين للقوات الاوكرانيه وافشل التنفيذ
تبادل القوات الاوكرانيه في اربع وحدات
عسكريه باتجاه محور كوبيانسك
في موازاه ذلك قالت القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه في بيان لها انها دمرت احدى
طائراتها المسيره بعد ان بدات في الطيران
خارجا نطاق السيطره على منطقه كييف وخلال
رحله جويه مخططه لها في كييف فقدت السيطره
على طائره بدون طيران ما دفع القوات
الجويه لاسقاطها البيان اضاف بان الطائره
بدون طيار ربما عانت من خلل فني وتاتي هذه
التطورات بعد اعلان موسكو اسقاط مسيرتين
فوق الكرملين يوم امس وهو الهجوم الذي
اتهمت موسكو واشنطن باعطاء الاوامر من اجل
تنفيذه
ارتفعت مستويات المياه قرب سد نوفا كخوفكا
الى مستوى قياسي تغمر معها السد الرئيسي
جنوب اوكرانيا نقلا وكاله تاس للانباروسيه
كما حضرت ريناتا مستشار المدير العام
لشركه الطاقه النوويه الروسيه من ان هذا
الارتفاع القياسي ينذر بتصدع الجسر
فالمياه ستغمر خط الكهرباء الواصل الى
محطات الضخ في محطه التي تسيطر عليها
موسكو مضيفا بان هذا سيؤدي الى مشاكل فنيه
لتشغيل المحطه ومخاطر على السلامه النوويه
تداول الناشطون على مواقع التواصل مقطع
فيديو اظهر عراكا بالايدي بين ممثل روسيا
ونظيره الاوكراني في قمه البحر الاسود
البرلمانيه للتعاون الاقتصادي في منطقه
بابسيك بتركيا واكدت مصادر لوكاله بان عضو
الوفد الاوكراني هاجم سكرتير الوفد الروسي
في القمه
[موسيقى]
في اخبار اخرى عن
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي انه سيزور
المملكه العربيه السعوديه مطلع الاسبوع
لاجراء محادثات مع قادتها ومناقشه مجالات
جديده للتعاون بين نيودلهي والخليج وكذلك
الولايات المتحده وبقيه المنطقه قال ان
خفض التصيد والتخلص من الارهاب هو من
اولويات الاداره الامريكيه في الشرق
الاوسط مشيرا الى ان الولايات المتحده
ستتخذ الاجراءات الضروريه لمنع ايران من
امتلاك السلاح النووي وانها ستسمح
لاسرائيل باتخاذ اللازم في حاله اقدمت
ايران على امتلاك هذا السلاح في سياقه
متصل انه سيتم الاعلان عن زياره رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو الى
واشنطن في الوقت المناسب اما في الشان
اليمني فاعلن سيلفا انه تم اتخاذ عدد من
الاجراءات لخفض التصعيد هنا
السعوديه في مطلع الاسبوع لاجراء محادثات
مع قادتها اذ تسعى الولايات المتحده الى
تطوير شراكتها مع الرياض كذلك سيزور
ممثلون للهند والامارات السعوديه
لمناقشه مجالات جديده للتعاون بين نيودلهي
والخليج وكذلك الولايات المتحده وبقيه
المنطقه وسوف نعلن عن زياره نتنياهو الى
واشنطن في الوقت المناسب
اعلنت ايران ان 4 الدبلوماسيين اداريين
بينهم اثنان من سفاره اذربيجان في طهران
واثنين من القنصليه العامه في تبريز
باعتبارهم عناصر غير مرغوب بها للبقاء على
الاراضي الايرانيه ياتي اعلان طهران بعد
الهجوم الذي وقع في السفاره الاثريه في
العاصمه الايرانيه واعلام باكو عن طرد
اربعه موظفين في السفاره الايرانيه من
باكو باعتبارهم عناصر غير مرغوب بها
استكملت السلطات البريطانيه استعداداتها
لحفل تتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث ومنذ عقود
ابدى الملك تشارلز الثالث اهتماما بالتعرف
على الثقافه العربيه والفن الاسلامي وكانت
المنطقه العربيه وجهته الاولى اثرى زوال
قيود مفروضه على السفر خلال جائحه كورونا
[موسيقى]
ليس سرا ان الملك تشارلز الثالث اقام
علاقات وثيقه مع العائلات الحاكمه في دول
الخليج ودول عربيه اخرى منذ عقود فعلى
مدار سنوات زار الملك تشارت عشره دوله
عربيه عده مرات
ركزت بشكل اساسي على تعزيز روابط بريطانيا
بها وبناء الثقه وفي طلعتها السعوديه التي
حل ضيفا عليها 10 مرات والتقى مع قادتها
بدءا من الملك فهد والملك عبد الله الى
الملك سلمان وولي عهده لارساء التواصل بين
مسؤول البلدين على اعلى المستويات والحفاظ
على الطابع الشخصي للعلاقات
اعتقد ان هذه الروابط ستستمر وعندما يقول
احدهم انه كان يقيم تلك العلاقات فاراها
انها اتت بشكل طبيعي من شخص كان مهتما حقا
بما قراه وما لاحظه بالاضافه الى انه شخص
عميق التفكير للغايه ولديه احساس قوي جدا
بالواجب الذي قام به حتى في ذلك الوقت وهو
يدرك ان دوره المستقبلي سيكون ملكا
لبريطانيا الحديثه يعرف عن الملك تشارلز
انه من اشد المهتمين بالثقافه العربيه
والاسلاميه في الغرب ويعتبر هذا الاهتمام
جزءا من رؤيته الشامله للتعايش والتفاهم
بين الثقافات المختلفه وهو من الداعمين
للحوار الدولي بين الاديان كاحد الوسائل
الفعاله لتعزيز السلام والتعاون بين
الشعوب
اتذكر محاضره القاها الملك عن الاسلام
والغرب في اكتوبر عام 93 واست فيها تعبيرا
عربيا يقول الذي يخرج من القلب يدخل القلب
والذي يخرج من اللسان لا يتجاوز الاذان
والقوه الحقيقيه لتلك المحاضره انها جاءت
من القلب وما كان يلفت انتباهنا هو اننا
لا نستطيع ان نعيش في سوء الفهم بين
العالمين الاسلامي والغربي والصور النمطيه
عن بعضنا البعض في اول زياره خارجيه لاحد
افراد العائله الملكيه البريطانيه منذ
جائحه كورونا زار الملك تشارلز رفقه
قرينته الملكه كاميلا مصر وتفقد اثارها
التاريخيه والجامعه الازهر كما سبقت
زيارته لمسجد الشيخ زايد في اطار تعزيز
قيم التسامح الديني واحترام التعدديه
الثقافيه
تشارلز شارك في العديد من المناسبات
الثقافيه والتراثيه العربيه ومنها مهرجان
الجنادريه بالرياض ورقص بالسيف متشحا الزي
السعودي الخاصه بالعارضه للملك تشارلز
الثالث علاقات وثيقه مع العالم العربي
ولطالما شجع على التفاهم والاحترام
المتبادل بلى الاديان وثقافات من منطلق ان
فهم الثقافه الاسلاميه والعربيه بشكل افضل
يمكن ان يساعد على تعزيز هذا الحوار
وتعميق فهم الاخرين مصطفى زارو العربيه
[موسيقى]
سيف الحار بانتظار العالم ان صحت التوقعات
في تحذيرات الامم المتحده من تشكل الظاهره
المناخيه النينيو هذا العام تؤرق العلماء
وتزيد المخاوف من تاثيراتها السلبيه على
العالم
ارتفاع متسارع في درجات حراره المحيطات
يؤرق العلماء ويزيد المخاوف من تاثير على
الاحتباس الحراري
تحذيرات اطلقتها الامم المتحده ترجح تشكل
ظاهره المناخيه هذا العام ما قد يدفع
درجات الحراره الى معدلات قياسيه جديده
اما المنظمه العالميه للارصاد الجويه
فتوقع التشكل الظاهره بحلول نهايه يوليو
بنسبه 60% وبحلول نهايه سبتمبر بنسبه 80%
المينيو ظاهره مناخيه طبيعيه تحدث في
المتوسط كل سنتين الى سبع سنوات وتستمر
عاده من تسعه الى 12 شهرا وترتبط عموما
بارتفاع درجات الحراره وزياده الجفاف بعض
انحاء العالم وبامطار غزيره في مناطق اخرى
ظاهره النينيو حدثت اخر مره في 2018 واتاح
تدمجال لحلقه طويله من ظاهره المينيا التي
تسبب اثارا عكسيه خصوصا درجات الحراره
لهذه الظاهره المناخيه عواقب وخيمه وتعتمد
اثارها جزئيا على التوقيت حيث تهدد
النينيو الحياه البحريه بالدرجه الاولى
لان الاسماك لا تستطيع مقاومتها ومقاومه
درجات الحراره المرتفعه اما تاثيره على
البشر فلا يقل ضررا حيث يمكن ان تسبب
الاعاصير وسط المحيط الهادئ وشرقه كارثه
تضرب السواحل فيما تتسبب بالجفاف في جزء
اخر من الارض ما يهدد مصادر الغذاء
العالمي المهدده اصلا بفعل الجفاف وتغير
المناخ
ذات ظاهره او مدتها لا يمكن توقعها
فموجتها الاخيره اعتبرت ضعيفه مقارنه
بالتي حدثت بين عامي 2014
وكانت لها عواقب وخيمه اياد حمود العربيه
مشاهدينا هذه التغطيه مستمره على راس
الساعه مع الزميل نايف الاحمري تفضلوا
بالبقاء معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج وال
قصص ساقيات وتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات